[Applause]
hi drew okay the ultimate
the ultimate girl you are such a
comedian's comedian
which you know is
is so cool because it's like all of our
heroes they all love you
oh that's a nice thing to say and and it
really means a lot like
i um i also think that a lot of
comedians
um do what we do because of some sort of
like pretty heavy-duty engagement with
self-doubt
one of the things that's hard about
being a comedian especially stand-up is
that you're like
if the audience doesn't laugh it means
they don't accept your work
you know and it means that like they're
not really into your point of view which
is like
personally devastating you know you're
always set up for a heartbreak
but you're also at the same time always
set up for um
a connection and uh you know proof that
that what comes from your heart is like
worth something
when you said you know you you put
yourself out there
and it's hard because it can be sort of
the most raw but it also can be the most
rewarding
yeah do you think you you don't probably
can't get one without the other
i haven't found a way yet
i'm really tired of sort of inwardly
shaming myself
for what i perceive as like a need
and um i'm kind of starting to suspect
that how i define
need is like probably pretty sexist um
and misogynist and um i just
want to place everything in a different
like paradigm where it's just like
these are the elements kind of like the
way i am in the world is like one of
those weird
rube goldberg machines you know where
like you put a ball in and it goes down
the thing and it hits the thing and then
the toast
pops out or whatever like i just wanted
to be like i think
need and hoping and
saying like i can't i can't exactly
control
um i can't control the outcome but i can
control like what i put in
i feel like you've been so good at
maintaining your whimsy though
i mean the book is like written by that
of eyes mind and heart of a
of such wonder and such a unique
funnel and then marcel the
shell oh my god my heart hurts when i
talk about marcel michelle
how did you come up with marcel dichelle
i was at a
wedding and and a bunch of my friends
and i were all staying in
one tiny hotel room and like there were
like people on cots and
it was just like why did we why did we
do this i don't remember but
um i felt so small oh and everybody was
like a man it was like all dudes
and i was like i felt so small and i
started to talk in that
little voice and um my partner at the
time dean fleischer camp was like oh
we could make something out of that one
time i nibbled on a piece of
cheese and my cholesterol went up to
900.
so we just made like a tiny little video
for
ourselves and put it on the internet
during a time when like
it was like a first an internet
phenomenon
everyone was talking about it before
there really was like that whole
internet exchange
yeah it was i mean i still remain like
very
computer negative and like in internet
negative i
um i've always been kind of scared of
the internet
because i don't love it when people
don't have to have accountabilities for
accountability for each other's feelings
and i sort of
sensed it as a like maybe a place where
things
might go wrong not that i'm psychic or
anything but um not that anything's
happened
but i i remember being like
even at that time being really excited
that so many people liked marcel
when he was not offering like any snark
or anything mean but he like truly is
just a little guy
with one eye and two shoes and he's just
kind of talking about his experience
and like that not only is that enough
for people but like
you know 36 million people for some
reason or another
are like oh i i get it
and it's hard to define like even what
you get even for me